so it's a short video of just like the
most condensed way we could show
somebody in like the more important
workflows but I think a much better way
is to Temp fate and let's do a live demo
on PC running on fortnite public servers
right here on stage uh welcome Michael
and Ray to the stage
take it away
[Applause]
helicopter
[Music]
thank you
I'm glad that went well
all right hey folks so let's talk about
how all this was made Michael here has
the scene open in unreal editor so we
can take a closer look
for the environment we built this level
using quixel Mega scan assets many of
which are available in the Fab uefn
plugin we also use custom content that
we built just for this demo
for the gameplay you just saw
we had we hand placed enemies using a
creative device called a guard spawner
which generates the aliens that you saw
at specific locations however we wanted
to do more and introduce Dynamic play
that goes beyond what the current
creative devices can do
so to do this we used our new
programming language called verse
so in this short section of code every
second we grab the position of the
player and for each spawn location we
then calculate the distance to the
player and if it's within a certain
threshold we tell that guard to spawn
into the level
so now we have gameplay that's more
reactive to the player's actions
this is just a short example of using
verse but for a deeper dive check out
the verse Tech talk later today
now Michael is going to show us how we
put the intro cinematic together hi
everybody so before the gameplay section
we played this a quick cinematic
animation this was actually created
entirely in uefn using sequencer
sequencers are multi-track editor and
it's been used in everything from
in-game cinematics to Hollywood feature
films so let's take a look uh now all
the stuff is available right inside uafn
so let's take a look at this last shot
from a slightly different perspective
so the other thing we featured in this
section was a bunch of Niagara Niagara
is now available in uefn and it's our
high-end VFX system
so and just like in the movies you can
frame up shots and have great effects so
what we're going to do here is just set
this up
so just look in the movies you can have
slow mode too makes everything better
right
so this is just a sampling of some of
the stuff that you can do inside
sequencer but let's get back to the game
all right so now that we're back in the
game in uefn you have access to
fortnite's time of day system or you
could use what we did and do what we did
and use a completely custom lighting
solution and thanks to Lumen both
daytime and night time look great now
let's go to the final gameplay section
and let's close out the demo
but as a reminder everything that you're
seeing here was created in the same
version of uefn that we're releasing
today I think I'm gonna jump in here and
help you right I am all for that
so
thank you
[Applause]